the government has already shelled the
bill that would be the end of it it
would not come back why should that be
endlessly for the arrested isn't that an
erosion of gruvlok you said you're gonna
give me time right so you let me finish
this is a heated discussion give me a
chance to answer my question plenty of
time but you stop interrupting then I
can answer weeks of mass protests in
Hong Kong show no sign of coming to an
end but how long will Beijing put up
with it my guest this week here in the
city is ronny tong a member of the hong
kong government cabinet and a senior
adviser to its chief executive Carrie
Lam do the authorities now accept of the
new extradition law which prevent the
crisis should be scrapped now and for
good
[Music]
ruddy tone welcome to conflicts on two
million people on the streets of Hong
Kong failures by the Hong Kong
government admitted by the chief
executive Carrie Lam why is she still
there why hasn't she resigned well I
think this is a more complex question
than simply asking why does she not
resign first of all I don't want to
argue about a figure but a more accurate
figure with more like half a million but
even then it's a very very large number
of people on the street and I think the
government accepted that the second
thing is that we must understand what
the government had been trying to do a
poll did by one of the more mainstream
newspapers of the people would turn out
in force to march on Sunday reviewed at
90 percent of the people who March
thought that the extradition bill was to
enable the Hong Kong government to send
people back to China for trial for
criticizing Beijing now they couldn't be
more wrong a tradition bill yeah about
extraditing people who committed a crime
across the border or outside the border
Hong Kong comes to Hong Kong and we need
to have a legal framework to see how we
nothing to do with any of the freedoms
or core values of the people in Hong
Kong it dies so why if that is so why
should achieve excited to resign because
deficiencies in the work of the
government you tell me which government
leader in the world have not made
mistakes these are huge mistake
these are huge mistake saying that you
should resign bill said very clearly
that it's got nothing to do with the
core values of freedoms of the people of
Hong Kong now the government has not
done its explanation thoroughly enough
true that is because of the fact that we
need to deal with a particular
criminal who is about to be released
very soon and that basically impacted
the period of consultation now that is
not ideal
I accept but this is not the sort of
thing that you say that because it's a
huge mistake
therefore the chief executive ought to
resign may be rewarding failure then no
I'm not admitting I am guilty of and he
did kind of admitted deficiencies in the
work of the government I personally have
to shoulder the responsibilities and the
anxieties in Surrey I mean you are being
unfair in her being she is basically
saying that she has not done the
consultation thoroughly enough that is
not something that any government would
take the blame and say the whole
government or they did the leader or the
Prime Minister whoever should resign as
I say which government leader in the
world have not made mistakes on me not
interview of you all right I give you
plenty of time you push a new
extradition bill that was widely seen as
an attempt to remove one of the key
legal safeguards Hong Kong's way of life
I know you do I know you scoffed at all
objections from farley the present bill
sorry the present statue I don't know
where you've read it or no I probably
have not because there have you read it
you probably wouldn't have put the
question the way you did the present law
was enacted not by the SI outcomes but
by the British colonial government
before they hand over the amendments no
talking about the statue I'm talking
about the amendment no she no I'm
talking about the statue you must read
the statue all right to understand what
is going on if you haven't even read it
you don't understand it and you
qualified to produce a you say let me
just finish I haven't not finished
yeah you said you're gonna give me time
right so you let me finish right okay
the statute was enacted by the British
Columbia government it followed very
closely the resolution of the United
Nations in 1990 are you saying that the
United Nations were suggesting that Hong
Kong should do something which is
contrary to human rights and core values
and freedoms then it's of course not
true now come to the amendment what the
amendment did was not to change the
legal framework oh it purports to do is
to extend the applicability of the
statue to China and the rest of the
world not talk about opinion respected
organizations mister time association
the Hong Kong law society the more
Society of England and Wales the
International Bar Association's Human
Rights Institute fair trials the defence
extradition lawyers forum Amnesty
International Human Rights Watch the
Speaker of the House of Representative
all of them challenge the suggestion by
your chief executive that the amendments
you want to make to the Hong Kong
extradition laws are in accordance with
international human what is it is they
also now say it is if you had you're the
only one who sees the truth know anyone
who sees the light then it's correct
yeah yeah from a rule of law point of
view you would think no one let alone
lawyers would object to this amendment
that's what you say as I say it follows
what you know to all your colleagues no
nothing if you're the only one who sees
the life a United Nations provided each
member state to do and we are following
take precise regime as the u.s. regime
as the UK regime Canadian regime
Australia Jim and nobody is making any
comment about those countries saying
that the judiciary in Hong Kong is not
up to this work it's near has to do it's
not my opinion the opinion of your own
you've got to look at the facts
Association is putting a travesty of the
facts to me
so the Hong Kong Bar Association is
putting a travesty of they are not
looking at the law they're not looking
at all these is capable of doing a
proper job of gatekeeping you say you
say that the these any decision that is
made by the chief executive is subject
to confirmation by the whole you
completely wrong criminal suspects can
be extradited without confirmation by
the Hong Kong courts can I say you know
can I ask you a question yeah you got
all the facts wrong what facts is if you
look at the statue you know that the
chief executive has no power to order
extradition it's clearly spell out in
the statue for one thing secondly all
that the chief executive can do is to
refuse extradition do you understand
what review exactly that was the final
decision is what refused that's the
final decision he can she can he or she
can only refused extradition he or she
cannot order extradition the only
institution which can order extradition
is the courts mr. Cheongdam the yeren
Bar Association points did not agree
with this the magistrate can I get the
question at the magistrate in Hong Kong
says the Bar Association does not have
the jurisdiction to inquire into the
quality of justice that the future enjoy
once surrender why am I going really you
are only talking about the committal
process yes the law has got two
processes one is the committal process
the other is about safeguarding and
protection of human rights and fair
trial which is being provided in Section
five of the statue has the
Society pointed out and so far as the
proposals would introduce any human
rights examinations at all
they are vested in Hong Kong's chief
executive or appear is wrong so the UK
law society goes it's wrong please pick
up the statue have a look before you
come to me and ask me questions you're
absolutely right that the judges and
magistrates of Hong Kong wouldn't dream
of currying favor with Beijing they
leave that to people like you don't they
you want to curry favor wholly unfair it
is not only unfair to me but if this is
really extremely unfair to the judges
judges are there to carry out the law if
they can't carry out the Lord they have
no business being judges all right I
have no power whatsoever i mediate
adviser to the government
I have no power because even the chief
executive herself has no power conferred
by the law
I keep telling and I haven't said it
sufficiently or enough times you have to
look at the law to understand what are
the facts if you don't say yes yes
because their opinions matter no I don't
think so the facts matter I'm sorry
travesty of the facts and the UK Law
Society who writes that the proposals in
the extradition bill fundamentally
imperiled the operation of the ruling in
Hong Kong rule of law in Hong Kong
they've got it wrong as well yeah I
don't understand
why do they think it would impair of the
rule of law in Hong Kong if all that is
happening he said they task of
scrutinizing any request for extradition
is to be considered by the judges mr.
Tong well no one is available in the
mainland
what kind of fair trial well fair trial
what the government has proposed is to
ensure that they would be open trial
that defensemen would be on the mainland
yes open since when do they have open
trials on the mainland are you are you
letting me answer the question yeah but
so please don't interrupt that's very
very and polite all right
this is a heated discussion chance to
answer plenty of time well you stop
interrupting then I can answer I'm
telling you that the government is
proposing to ensure that there will be
assurances of open trial this defendant
will have the choice of his own lawyer
the trial has to be proceeded on the
basis that it will be in the language
which he understands that would be
visitation rights all these the minimum
guarantees of article 14 of the ICCPR do
you know what ICCPR is International
Covenant of Civil and Political Rights
right it's a charter for human rights
the government is saying that Miss China
has not ratified I'm not with China I'm
talking about Hong Kong because the
gatekeeping is in Hong Kong a fair trial
that a different terming can expect in
the mainland if there is no guarantee
that there would be the minimum
requirements of article 14 of ICCPR it
is written in the law there then the
court has no business of ordering a
extradition even if the court were to
order an extradition the chief exciting
will veto it because as I keep repeating
Li telling you that the chief excited
has no power to order extradition but
has power to veto an order for
extradition
are you following they're unlikely the
chief executive is unlikely to a request
from China based on what fact do you say
it is unlike she's an appointee of China
so isn't she so so is she going to stand
up to China suddenly and say this go
through this on what basis do say that
she would not do that based on the human
rights record in China the civil and she
little rights in China she I ever order
in a tradition of any suspect to China
has she your you tell me no you tell me
I don't know you tell me there has not
been a single occasion that that
happened we're talking about when it
does happen from doing so did you read
the latest human rights reports about
what happens in Germany the UK report in
2011 I'm asking about the huge majority
okay
20:11 I must get the latest report
commission says that it is paramount
that you should respect each member
states on judicial system even where
those civil and political rights
attention Road you know in China know
the continuing detention and child of
human rights I'm telling you both in the
UN resolution and in the UK report in
2011 made it very clearly that
protection of human rights and
extradition are not mutually exclusive
that is why that you've got to frame
your legal regime in the way that hong
kong is doing to ensure and the ke
keeping is in the local judiciary not in
anywhere else in the world to ensure
that any suspect any defender would be
entitled to fair trial and protection of
human rights when the extradition is
being carried out that is the way in
which all extradition arrangements mr.
truck is being area the well over that
so no country is different mr. tone what
expectation can there be of a fair trial
in China when civil and political rights
according to the latest British human
rights and democracy report rights
continue to be erode can I just read
what they said the continuing detention
and trials of human rights lawyers and
defenders lack of due process and
judicial transparency remained important
concerns I don't want to sound a face
okay how can you have how can you have
an expectation of a fair trial for
anyone that is extradited I don't want
to sound offensive but how could anyone
expect a fair trial to be heard in Syria
Iraq we're not talking about Syria
they're talking about mainland China why
do you think I'll try though I'm because
this is the whole point of that have
been taking place in Hong Kong Hong Kong
people will apply the same standard no
matter who is coming to make the request
be it United case the United States you
know
Syria Russia China we apply the same
standard because this is what the law
requires us to do and we will do it
period what you understand the purpose
of extradition you want understood what
I'm saying but obviously you know you
know what's what what's your guess mr.
Todd instead of throwing insults at me
what's your guess about where this is
headed
well the hardliners in Beijing try to
teach Hong Kong a lesson no will they
show that they're willing to learn one
hour from what's being taken but the
facts say that it did not come from
mainland I think the chief executive is
explained very clearly that he was her
own initiative based on the fact that
she was asked by the family of the girl
who unfortunately was murdered by this
Hong Kong person in Taiwan because of
the whole injustice of the situation
the chief excited to agree to look into
it and she was asked to to establish an
extradition regime which can apply to
Taiwan apply to the rest of the world
which includes China a China is very
exercised about what's been happening
here let's go did a diver if you direct
challenge to one country two systems'
you were right China would not have
permitted the chief executive to shelf
the bill I don't know that go on well as
far as this administration is concerned
I understand that it's not gonna come
back period it's dead in the last few
days so it's just tell me right if what
you say were true why we're trying to do
it the fact is you don't you do I don't
ask me for for for for an interview
would you in the rice if you know all
the answers you would have come to me
with the last few days tomorrow the
Association has called for a credible
commission of inquiry not the Police
Complaints Council but a statutory
independent body that can compel
documents to be submitted is that going
to happen is they're going to be do you
want it to happen because did yes I yeah
I have made clear that I
I'm getting good agreement with that
request but the capo sorry the IPS CCD
Independent Police Complaints Council
has already embarked on a full inquiry
there is only one investigation subject
which is the police the police has
already promised that it would comply
with all requests and and provide for
cooperation the government has made the
same promise
so that inquiry would be a very
sufficient inquiry but if at the end of
the day come on our associations is not
sufficient the only thing you know what
to say it says quota by association
without looking the facts I didn't say
that but I don't know what facts they
looked at but I'm telling you what the
facts are all right now if at the end of
the day the IC IPCC inquiry proved to be
insufficient or inadequate then of
course we can look at to see whether
there are other ways to implement or to
improve what is being done but enquiry
is going to be carried out right so
entry into what the Hong Kong government
did or didn't do well that has been
looked at trailed by everybody it's its
own deficiencies that it's gonna change
his ways to listen more and try to gauge
more public opinion I didn't listen
it has listened before but this
particular 20 days consultation I have
already explained to you why that is so
have you heard one on my explanation it
was because that this criminal was to be
set free in September and he's going to
leave Hong Kong if there is no law in
place that is the reason but and the
only reason why there have been
insufficient consultation what the
demands from the protesters
already sell the bill that would be the
end of it it would not come back right
so it's finished it's finished it's dead
and what about the demands from the
protesters scrapped the bill independent
inquiry that's good a scrap in
independent inquiry into public ICCC
amnesty if any arrested white why should
that be endlessly for the arrested
isn't that an erosion of rule of law
you've been telling me that the rule of
law cannot be eroded so you're now
telling me crimes committed serious
crime committed including we can try the
fine of course there is a tape have you
watch a TV tape there's also a
presumption of in the snow have you
watched a TV tape yes I have thrown
bricks there if somebody has from a
break you're telling me they're guilty
anyone know you wait for me to answer
you I mean why are you being so unfair
why putting questions which are the
questions my damn mister tried to ask
you a question I'm asking you if there's
a clip which shows somebody has thrown a
brick that means somebody has committed
an offense right now whether that person
is right liquor arrested or not is for
the court to decide so you can't say
that somebody has been arrested that
arrest must be wrong that is nothing to
do with presumption of innocence you
understand that I understand that mr
toura
few days ago you were warning and you're
trying to evade it at the point mr. the
point is that if you got somebody who'd
be arrested let the Court decide whether
he's guilty or not by simply asking that
you should let him go without going
through a due process of the law is an
extreme erosion of the rule of law and
you are seeing there on your high horse
and you're telling me that the bill is
eroding the rule of law and yet you are
pulling to me at the same time that
freedom giving freedom or letting the
arrested go free it's not erosion of the
rule of law you you won't come
such double-standard you warned a few
weeks a few days ago that if things got
worse the Chinese army might consider
taking to the streets you said when
there's trouble in Hong Kong when things
turn sour there's violence in our street
our fear is that if the police are no
able to control what is happening here
there's a remote risk the Chinese army
would get involved how remote is that
risk if it's so why did you why did you
mention it no I hope you will never
happen why did you mention if risk are
you trying to frighten people no it's a
fact everybody understands that except
you you don't understand it Hong Kong is
a place where it is being operating it's
operating under the one country two
systems'
it is a not very successfully is it calm
is a huge political compromise we are
part of China under the basic law china
has a responsibility to ensure that Hong
Kong is stable everybody who is doing
business here want to see Hong Kong to
be stable alright so yes under the basic
law there is provision for the the
Beijing government to interfere if
nobody hoped that it would happen I'm
trying to say that we are trying our
ankles to have avoid this happening so
I'm not instilling fear into people's
are I'm simply reflecting what is stated
in the basic law and what is the
political reality of the situation you
said we need we in a perfectly
responsible thing to do you said we need
we in Hong Kong need to gain the trust
and confidence in aging so that they can
allow us the freedom of political reform
what about the what about Beijing's duty
to earn the trust of people in Hong Kong
ways they've been doing their utmost to
try the opinion polls all show that
people do not know the majority of
people still do not identify
everybody who's got to work harder you
think the people of Hong Kong should
play nice to their masters in Beijing
and they might throw them a few crumbs
the words I use is that we should
communicate with each other and which
instill confidence in each other that's
what I'm saying
UNITA stand the difference Ronny Tong
it's been good to have your own
conflicts oh thank you very much
[Music]